we're talking about Miranda Lambert and
Brendan McLaughlin they are going on
four years of marriage so what's their
secret well I caught up with Miranda in
her home state of Texas for this
certified country exclusive
what do you just love about this man I
love that he's supportive and kind and
also calls me yeah which I need
how do you all roll whenever you got
your down time you're not in work mode
do you like having quiet drinks at home
or do you prefer to have a Rowdy night
out on the town we do a little of both I
mean he's from New York city so he loves
a good night out but you know a lot of
times we just sit on the porch and have
a beverage and chill and listen to music
I mean that's my vibe and his Vibe is
going out so we balance each other
really well when Miranda is ready to
turn up she grabs A Lone River cocktail
we were on sets as she shot a new promo
for the brand ready and action
it started on a ranch by mixing tequila
soda and lime she's been somebody that
I've just always been so inspired by so
it was kind of like a pie in the sky
dream of could we ever work with her
another partnership we'd love to see a
Miranda Cameo on Yellowstone they are
clearly fans of yours Miranda they got
some posters and Miranda Lambert episode
my baby posters I was like
19. you could pull a lady Wilson we're
like you're singing your songs you're
also you know doing a cameo on the show
I've never been an actress it's not my
favorite thing if I can play myself
which I am today that's a little bit
easier on me
thank you